yeah hello world welcome to this video
playing the mastermind Isco Milan AHA
from Slovakia okay I play the slob I
don't do that much on video but i played
this chillin n covariation quite a bit
in um in the 1990s somewhat afterwards
so oops 1990s more than 2,000 some sorry
this line wow I'm blanking out I have no
idea what did i do here we should chief
is kind of tricky as I remember I don't
know this is not exactly great
white OS has a four and then potential
sacrifices on b5 later a lot later and
down this often tough to defend
wow that's a bad position I mean it's
not like oh but it's not great my bishop
1c8 that's what you get for playing an
opening that you don't know well okay so
i don't i cannot even go if 5pm we can
take a take Boyle I can maybe take
technology forum that's probably
playable you know I think it's probably
playable and if I can get this in I
should maybe you can't eat with the pawn
Knight g4 then II for something like
that it could be rather annoying maybe I
can play 95 mmm
yeah I think well let's let's not be too
quick them I thought I can do here 90 x
90 x 90 x through canada the bishop
hangs and it's not bad come on and i can
even take with the bishop p.m. which is
kind of interesting Bishop takes Ray's
got age three after that I don't have a
clear continuation but 90 x is that bad
I don't see why this is so bad yeah but
i have pick up g form as one that's one
thing do you give d 492 bishop is six
quincy to it's not quite working it's
closed down
I wonder if Bishop chief is interesting
let's do that maybe just plays Bishop e2
mer ok I have deform it's technically
interesting we had that then I couldn't
really believe I think I can as I come
on that that's going that's works I
don't need to calculate it come on that
cannot be right Green g5 and Bishop g4
check what you're just you just not like
believing me anything here like this out
yeah that couldn't work him just
allowing all the sacrifice on f3 I
thought we should be two years to go ok
anyway and that was surprising from a
position that I didn't like at all
winning in a couple of moves ok queen
bee three he went away I go if five I
think I have to have everything is kind
of set for that move it took in naija
for ya important is that I cannot just
recapture now i'll do some super
important pawn but this now ok the
engine now wants to go e six here v6
rook cheeks and night 22 now that makes
quite some sets up putting the night
maybe over here attacking this pawn this
is what the computer gifts and after
here here it calls it equal so I'm not
in such bad shape ok by getting a five
that Bishop has a clear idea what it
wants to do even d7 is not so awful
covering cedar oops covering c6 but he
went here and this is already yeah
there's already winning for black for
here amazingly with Bishop b5 though
okay okay okay I should have taken with
the bishop
yeah okay this is what i did not see i
can go here I didn't pay any attention
to that more interesting okay now group
do you want and then i can probably
sacrifice yes room i can take a second
prize here amazing I mean he's got lots
of stuff over on the queenside okay and
this is a win for black with Queen age
three yeah okay thats it's tough tough
tough to see I mean it's actually I I
just didn't think about 9 h 2 a.m. I
mean once you see the move it's clear
that it's dangerous even I def side is
an interesting move how that also wins
actually and this this for Queen g5 also
winning for black the should see one and
queen age for you have to serve let's
just a great attack okay i took with and
with this and here Queen age for was
strong I went with this though and I was
thinking the ship here and and d4 that
was my idea that is just a slight
advantage though way it's pretty good
yeah he has to take and give me that
pawn no it's pretty good but this is
just not working on a bishop t4 is also
strong but that wins I'm threatening
Queen g5 Bishop g4 chair Queen age for
just attacking with all pieces that so
it's completely over check yet here you
resigned if he goes here check check
check make a couple of funky checkmates
okay well thanks for watching